i think a lot of parents need to step up  and say [ __ ] the school  the conversation my mother had with me  was very simple which is you're gonna  get grounded if you get bad grades  because i want to teach you  accountability you do something  something happens however nothing about  school defines you you're the best  you're incredible at these other things  you're a little lazy with school and i'm  not pumped about and you're gonna get  grounded kind of fake two weeks not  really she always stopped after three  days and she did it right a lot of  parents can't take their kids out can't  take in private school they definitely  can't afford that can't take them  homeschooling they can't afford that or  they don't want to and that's okay too  but the convo they have with their kids  should be i want you to be a good person  you need to be kind of respectful but if  you get these refs you're gonna be just  fine